A little meditation, plenty of Mai Tais--
Bruce Banner's recovery during the
Blip was nothing short of incredible.
Marvel Studios' Phase 4 slate has
focused on new characters and new
worlds in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
for the current era of the franchise,
officially titled "The Multiverse Saga,"
and the "She-Hulk" series adds Jennifer
Walters to the roster. In the comics, she's a
high-flying lawyer who gets a blood transfusion
from her cousin Bruce Banner after she gets
shot by mobsters in "Savage She-Hulk" #1.
But the Gamma radiation in his blood transforms
Jen into She-Hulk. Who could've seen that coming?
Thankfully, the series takes a different approach
to Jen's origin, as Bruce's blood spills into her
wound when the cousins get involved in a car
accident in the first episode of "She-Hulk."
This makes sense because Banner would
know about the dangers of purposefully
giving his cousin a blood transfusion
considering his own unique condition.
The show also pulls from John Byrne's "The
Sensational She-Hulk" comics, which see the hero
break the fourth wall to talk to the reader. Head
writer Jessica Gao told The Hollywood Reporter
that she originally wanted to use that format
in an even bigger way in the series. She said,
"It was tricky finding the balance because if
I had my way, she'd be breaking the fourth wall
every other sentence. Everybody had to
pull me back a little bit more from it."
Jennifer breaking the fourth wall injects
the series with a sense of fun, especially
opposite Ruffalo's Professor Hulk, who teaches
his cousin how to handle her newfound abilities.
"If you want to go back to your life
as a lawyer, I, I respect that."
"Thanks…He doesn't mean that."
But while Jen and Bruce catch up, the
scientist reveals what the Hulk did
during the Blip after Thanos erased
half of all life in the universe.
The world drastically changed in the five years
between "Avengers: Infinity War" and "Avengers:
Endgame" due to half the population disappearing
as a result of the Snap. But when fans see Hulk
again in "Endgame," Bruce Banner has figured out
a way to combine his alter-ego's strength and
size next to his own intellect and personality.
It's a surprising development for the scientist,
but it's one that allows him to still be
part of the action while also pushing his
character arc further. But "She-Hulk" Episode 1
reveals that it wasn't an easy feat to pull off.
Bruce tells Jennifer that he
spent much of his time alone
in his remote Mexican laboratory
which was funded by Tony Stark.
"But this is where I spent the Blip fixing myself
and integrating the Hulk/Banner identities."
Bruce created a device there to
help him control his two sides,
putting the brains and the brawn together. This
lab would also be where Bruce healed his arm
after the events of "Endgame," as he was
fairly injured from using the Stark Gauntlet.
It's great that Banner spent his
time productively during the Blip,
but it's hard not to think that he
could've been doing more out in the world.
Bruce could have helped Natasha Romanoff
try and keep the world from falling apart
with the remaining Avengers during the Blip. She's
not doing so great at the start of "Avengers:
Endgame" because of everything she's been
through, and Bruce could have been there for her.
After all, once upon a time, the two
were very close in "Age of Ultron."
In the first act of "Avengers: Endgame,"
most of the surviving heroes work together
during the fallout. Nebula, Rocket,
Okoye, Captain Marvel, and War Machine
are all doing their part across Earth and
the universe. The fact that Bruce hid out in
Mexico trying to work on his new Smart Hulk ego
and not helping his friends is quite unusual.
Regardless of his absence during the blip,
it's safe to say that if Professor Hulk
had not come to be, Jessica Walter's
transition into She-Hulk would have been
much harder to handle, or might
not have even happened at all.